[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna pareigis herzlich willkommen an
diesem montagabend zudem nachrichten und
da werfen wir im sport auch noch mal
einen letzten blick nach münchen auf die
european championships schon so
genannter von mir und diese themen haben
wir heute für sie
kanzler und vizekanzler auf schatzsuche
in kanada wollen habeck und scholz eine
energiepartnerschaft für die zukunft
schließen
streit um weitere entlastungen die rufe
nach gezielten hilfen für studierende
rentner und geringverdiener werden
lauter und
moskau macht hierfür anschlag
verantwortlich rätselraten um tödliche
autobombe gegen die tochter eines putin
ideologen
rund 7000 kilometer von deutschland
entfernt soll eine lösung unserer
energieprobleme legen und so sind
kanzler scholz und vizekanzler harbeck
heute in kanada eingetroffen es geht um
die lieferung von kanadischen
wasserstoff und verflüssigtem gas und
auch der ukraine krieges thema johannes
hano über die energiepartnerschaft
es ist ein sehnsuchtsort für viele von
magischer schönheit und zauber der natur
doch kanada das zweitgrößte land der
erde ist auch einer der größten öl und
gasproduzenten der welt und kaum ein
land hat einen größeren co2 ausstoß pro
kopf kann er damit seine energiebilanz
verbessern und deutschland will sich aus
der russischen energie abhängigkeit
befreien und so geht es bei dem
dreitägigen besuch des bundeskanzlers in
kanada auch darum die probleme beider
länder langfristig in eine
win-win-situation zu verwandeln wir sind
also zwei länder und zwei regierung die
gemeinsame ziel verfolgen wenn es darum
geht die zukunft unseres planeten zu
sichern klimaneutral zu werden und den
menschengemachten klimawandel
aufzuhalten und gleichzeitig den
wohlstand unserer nationen zu sichern
eine langfristige energie partnerschaft
wollen beide regierungen bei dem besuch
einfädeln wichtigstes projekt aber eine
anlage für grünen wasserstoff die an der
rauen küste fundplatz entstehen soll so
der wirtschaftsminister der den
bundeskanzler auf der reise begleitet
die kanadische regierung bereitet sich
darauf vor grünen wasserstoff also durch
erneuerbare energien hergestelltem
wasserstoff zu produzieren vor allem in
der region neufundland ideale
windbedingungen dafür und wir haben
erstens ein technisches know how und
zweitens einen großen bedarf noch aber
wurde noch nicht einmal mit dem bau
begonnen eine lösung der probleme beider
länder liegt so noch in ferner zukunft
und auf der kanada reise des kanzlers
und vizekanzler ist theo koll für uns
dabei theo es gibt noch hürden aber wie
schnell kann es gehen mit dieser energie
partnerschaft
also sehr schnell wird es nicht geben
gehen das wird jetzt das wasserstoff
abkommen unterzeichnet aber die erste
lieferung soll dann erst ab 20 25 kommen
der kanzler hat heute noch mal betont
mit blick in die zukunft des wasserstoff
ein massiver wichtiger teil der
wirtschaft werden wird und die weichen
würden jetzt gestellt dass
gesellschaften demokratische
gesellschaften in der lage sind solche
langfristigen energie entscheidungen zu
treffen und dass sie jetzt die weichen
stellen weg von fossilen energien das
ist etwas was offensichtlich putin
ausgelöst hat durch seinen krieg und was
er auch massiv unterschätzt hat die
beiden länder deutschland und kanada
sind sich nah die beiden regierungschefs
auch bezeichnen sich als freunde und man
rückt immer näher zusammen der kanzler
hat sich heute übrigens auch noch mal
bedankt für die freigabe der siemens
turbine die ja hier unter sanktionen
festgehalten war und tritte der hier
kritisiert wurde im land es gibt eine
starke ukrainische minderheit sagte das
hat er bewusst getan um im grunde putins
argumentation auch zu entzaubern also
man sieht die zeitenwende verändert im
grunde die weltkarte und kanada wird
einen viel wichtigeren teil spielen auch
in deutschlands zukunft planung für die
energie einschätzung von theo koll
dankeschön
mittelfristig soll also gas aus kanada
kommen kurzfristig wird das jedoch
nichts und so sind die gaspreise weiter
hoch mit der gas umlage sollen ja daher
gasversorger unterstützt werde zwölf
unternehmen haben jetzt ansprüche
angemeldet von insgesamt rund 34
milliarden euro so das
gemeinschaftsunternehmen der
gasnetzbetreiber
angesichts weiter steigender
energiepreise fordert die
bundesfamilienministerin das niemandem
wegen geldnot das gas abgestellt werden
solle sie spreche sich klar für das
verbot von strom und gas sperren aus sub
aus und der druck auf die ampelkoalition
steigt sich bald auf das dritte
entlastungs paket zu einigen mehr dazu
von patricia wieder meyer wer soll man
wie entlastet werden nach wie vor wird
darüber in der koalition gestritten der
grünen chef forderte heute das dritte
entlastungspaket müsse parallel zur gas
umlage kommen also zum ersten oktober es
ist für uns klar dass die entlastung das
dritte entlastungspaket parallel kommen
muss zur einführung der
gasanlage und es gibt eine reihe von
vorschlägen die auf dem tisch sind die
grünen wollen diesmal vor allem
geringverdiener auch studierende und
rentner stärker entlasten als
besserverdienende einen sozialen
ausgleich fordert wirtschaftsminister
harbeck aus dem fernen kanada
gasrechnung die kosten sind ja kommen
wir auf alle zu dann sollten nicht
diejenigen die 60 80 hunderttausend euro
verdienen mehr bekommen als diejenigen
die vielleicht 16 18 oder nur 12.000
euro verdienen in berlin wird weiter
diskutiert finanzminister lindner von
der fdp will die kalte progression
abmildern steuern senken mehr für die
arbeitende mitte tun unterstützt wird er
dabei von der union es geht ja nicht nur
um das die großabnehmer von energie
entlastet werden so wie es herr habeck
vor hat sondern auch die kleinen
bäckereien die mittelständler die
dezentral bei uns im ganzen land sind
dass man ihnen auch behilflich ist die
linke geht noch weiter fordert wegen der
steigenden heiz und strompreise ein
winter geld in höhe von 1500 euro
natürlich kann man darüber reden ob man
besonders hohe einkommen jetzt
entsprechend nicht mit den 1500 euro
versorgt das ist vielleicht auch
sinnvoll aber wir müssen jetzt endlich
mal handeln und es geht nicht dass so
viele menschen im regen stehen gelassen
werden
so wird immer dramatischer nichts werde
derzeit mehr diskutiert als die frage
der weiteren entlastung versicherte die
regierung konkrete es gab es heute
jedoch nicht
wer ist für den bombenanschlag in moskau
verantwortlich bei dem die tochter des
rechts nationalistischen ideologen
alexander dugin getötet wurde in einem
video hat sich eine bisher unbekannte
russische partisanen gruppe dazu bekannt
der russische geheimdienst fsb dagegen
gibt der ukraine die schuld und mahnte
eine ukrainerin als täterin kiew hatte
das bereits zurückgewiesen
ralph goldmann berichtet
zwei tage nach dem anschlag zeigt das
russische staatsfernsehen an
kondolenzschreiben von präsident putin
er würdigte ihn als patrioten russlands
sie war am samstagabend auf einer
hauptstraße in moskau durch die
explosion einer autobombe ums leben
gekommen die 29 jährige galt als
kremltreue journalistin sie hatte den
krieg in der ukraine offen unterstützt
wir können bestätigen sagt eine
sprecherin des ermittlungskomitees dass
der sprengsatz unter dem auto auf der
fahrerseite angebracht wurde daria
dugginger saß am steuer und starb am
tatort
russland macht die ukraine für den
anschlag verantwortlich die ukraine wies
das zurück auch der sicherheitsexperte
nico lange hält das für unwahrscheinlich
er gibt aus ukrainischer perspektive
keinen sinn sich mit frau dubina zu
beschäftigen die hat im kreml nichts
entschieden die führt auch diesen krieg
nicht
dass der kreml in so kurzer zeit
erklärung hat es etwas dass er die sache
unglaubwürdig macht ein ehemaliger
russischer oppositionsabgeordneter
berichtete heute die sogenannte bisher
unbekannte nationale republikanische
armee stecke hinter dem anschlag
ist zum jetzigen zeitpunkt schwer zu
beurteilen ob das ein echtes bekenntnis
ist und ob es tatsächlich gewalttätigen
widerstand gibt in russland das wäre
bemerkenswert
möglicherweise galt das attentat aber
auch ninas vater alexander er gilt also
rechtsnationalistische ideologe hatte
die idee einer eurasischen union unter
russischer führung videos in den
sozialen netzwerken zeigen ihn kurz nach
der tat am ort des anschlags russlands
feinde hätten seine tochter gemein und
heimtückisch umgebracht sagte er
und noch mehr einschätzung des
sicherheitsexperten nico lange gibt es
ab 19.30 bei zdf heute live zu sehen auf
unseren social media kanälen und in der
zdf- heute dort beantworten wie außerdem
fragen zu alexander du ins radikale
ideologie und seine verbindungen zur
rechtsextremen in deutschland
russlands angriffskrieg dauert bereits
fast ein halbes jahr die ukraine meldet
heute neue opferzahlen und spricht von
9000 eigenen soldaten die gefallen sind
und die vereinten nationen zählen
offiziell knapp 6000 getötet
zivilistinnen und zivilisten
die tatsächliche zahl dürfte wesentlich
höher liegen heißt es zum
unabhängigkeitstag am mittwoch
befürchtet die ukraine verstärkte
angriffe einer hebestreit berichtet
kunst als unterstützung für die truppe
ukrainische kinder haben helme bemalt in
odessa werden sie verkauft wird dem
erlös sollen regenjacken für die armee
angeschafft werden es ist eine der
aktionen rund um den 31 jahrestag der
ukrainischen unabhängigkeit am mittwoch
und die letzte öffentliche alle anderen
wurden abgesagt
wir können nicht ausschließen dass der
feind unser nationalfeiertag angreift
deshalb bitten wir alle sehr vorsichtig
zu sein
werden die feier nachholen sobald wir
gesiegt haben
solche veranstaltungen mit grossem
öffentlichen zulauf gelten in der
ukraine in den nächsten drei tagen als
zu gefährlich die behörden warnen vor
einer erheblichen gefahr russischer
luftangriffe rund um den
nationalfeiertag am mittwoch sämtliche
veranstaltungen im öffentlichen raum
wurden abgesagt eisenbahnverbindungen
auf ein minimum reduziert und in einigen
städten wie zum beispiel kharkiv wurde
sogar eine dreitägige ausgangssperre
verhängt befürchtet werden auch
schauprozesse moskautreue separatisten
gegen gefangene ukrainische verteidiger
des stahlwerks von mario pohl in kiel
für ihnen zu ehren eine fotoausstellung
gezeigt
sollte es zu diesem prozess kommen sind
wir an einem punkt an dem verhandlungen
keinen sinn mehr machen russland würde
sich damit von allen weiteren gesprächen
ausschließen
der bedrohung rund um den
nationalfeiertag sehen die menschen in
odessa einigermaßen gelassen entgegen
ich
aus als würde ich mich für irgendetwas
fürchten die sollten angst vor mir haben
in der ukraine hat man nach fast einem
halben jahr krieg offenbar gelernt mit
der russischen bedrohung zu leben
nach berlin dort hat ron prosor als
neuer israelischer botschafter seine
arbeit aufgenommen er sagte er kehre
zurück zu den deutschen wurzeln seiner
familie als stolzer israeli und
vertreter des jüdischen staates bronze
erhielt eine sehr persönliche rede auf
dem bebelplatz dem ort der
bücherverbrennung 1933
damals war seine familie ins heutige
israel geflohen seine akkreditierung
hatte der 63 jährige zuvor von
bundespräsident steinmeier erhalten
die abberufene rbb-intendantin
schlesinger wird fristlos entlassen sie
soll auch keine abfindung oder hohe
geldzahlungen erhalten beschloss der
verwaltungsrat des rundfunks berlin
brandenburg wegen vorwürfen der
vetternwirtschaft vorteilsnahme und
verschwendung war schlesinger vor zwei
wochen zurückgetreten
es war eine der schlimmsten
rassistischen ausschreitungen der
deutschen nachkriegsgeschichte zur
bundesinnenministerium feser das pogrom
von rostock lichtenhagen vor genau 30
jahren anlässlich des jahrestages
forderte bundeskanzler scholz die bürger
innen auf jeden tag gegen hetze und
rassismus zu kämpfen
1992 belagerten attackierten hunderte
rechte gewalttäter tage lang das
sogenannte sonnenblumenhaus warfen
steine und brandsätze in dem gebäude
wohnten asylsuchende und vietnamesische
vertragsarbeiter und arbeiterinnen
150 menschen mussten um ihr leben bangen
susanne seidel
ein aggressiver mock stimmt in rostock
lichtenhagen ein wohnheim von
vietnamesen und legt feuer unbehelligt
von der polizei und angefeuert von
anwohnern
die polizeikräfte sind angesichts der
gewalt überfordert und ziehen sich für
zwei stunden zurück freie bahn für den
mob
die menschen im haus in todesangst mit
dabei der damalige ausländerbeauftragte
wolfgang richter er ist heute überzeugt
die rostocker zivilgesellschaft hat sich
seitdem verändert
wenn es die 92 schon gegeben hätte dann
hätten nicht nur die steinewerfer und
die kölner vor dem aus gestanden sondern
dann hätten auch andere menschen hier
gestanden und hatten uns in diesem haus
hierbei gestanden unterstützt 30 jahre
später das erinnern an die krawall
nächte sollte deutlich machen dass
rassismus auch heute noch ein
gesamtdeutsches problem ist und nicht
nur von lichtenhagen so die
integrationsbeauftragte des landes das
ist eine riesige wunde dieser bunde ist
irgendwie verheilt aber gleichzeitig
auch nicht und wir müssen immer wieder
gucken dass es so was nie wieder
passiert in rostock wirken inzwischen
mehr als 60 initiativen für eine bessere
integration geflüchteter mehrere stehlen
erinnern an die krawalle 1992 alle orte
rassistische angriffe wie lichtenhagen
aber auch hanau und halle müssten
sichtbarer werden fordert claudia roth
sie sind teil unserer realität und diese
gedenkorte die machen ja auch deutlich
dass wir als gesamtgesellschaft dieses
leid der opfer und der hinterbliebenen
auch als unser leid verstehen das
damalige versagen des staates wurde nie
gänzlich aufgeklärt eine bürde die
rostock lichtenhagen bis heute tragen
muss wenn
in deutschland von geflüchteten die rede
ist denken die meisten an menschen aus
der ukraine und dem nahen osten aber
auch in südamerika spielt sich derzeit
ein flüchtlingsdrama ab mehr als sechs
millionen menschen haben venezuela
verlassen die misswirtschaft der
sozialistischen regierung hatte zu einer
humanitären krise geführt nachbar
kolumbien nach mehr als zwei millionen
von ihnen auf in der hauptstadt bogotá
hat sich deutschlands entwicklungs
ministerin schulze einen eindruck von
der lage verschafft christoph präparat
berichtet
keine 50 kilo wog manuell als er sich
vor knapp drei wochen mit seiner familie
in die flüchtlingsunterkunft schleppte
dank der einrichtung dank des essens
hier sagt seine frau europa geht es ihm
schon viel besser wie ihr seht hat er
sogar etwas zugenommen wir sind in
bogotá in eine erstaufnahmeeinrichtung
für flüchtlinge aus venezuela mehr als
zweieinhalb millionen menschen hat
allein kolumbien aufgenommen eine
immense aufgabe gefördert auch von
deutschland entwicklungsministerin
svenja schulze macht sich ein bild von
der arbeit der einrichtung müssen auch
als deutschland interesse haben uns um
lateinamerika zu kümmern das sind hier
demokratien immer weniger menschen leben
in demokratischen staaten und deswegen
müssen demokratien sich auch gegenseitig
stärken darüber hinaus sagt die
ministerin könne deutschland auch etwas
lernen von kolumbien wenn es um den
umgang mit und die integration von
geflüchteten geht die migrationspolitik
kolumbiens gilt weltweit als vorbildlich
aufenthaltsgenehmigungen sowie der
zugang zum arbeitsmarkt und den
sozialsystemen werden großzügig und
langfristig erteilt und doch dürfte
jedes system an seine grenzen stoßen
solange der strom der menschen nicht
abreißt in venezuela ist keine
verbesserung der lage in sicht
was sich am meisten dort vermisse oder
vermissen könnte gibt es nicht mehr
viele meiner verwandten sind gestorben
und damit auch unsere fröhlichkeit
die not der menschen kann man lindern
den verlust der heimat aber nicht
kommen wir zurück nach deutschland zu
dir norbert die european championship
chips gehen jetzt zu ende war das doch
nicht so ein tolles event das ist
wirklich schade ich weitermachen und das
kann man wohl laut sagen ja ein
begeistertes publikum in münchen
mitreißende sportlerinnen und sportler
ja uns geradezu hinreißende deutsche
erfolge auch gestern abend der goldenen
abschluss in der leichtathletik mit dem
sieg der 4 x 100 meter staffel der
frauen
die jubelsprünge bis zuletzt gefüllt war
es eine riesen party im münchner
olympiastadion der letzte paukenschlag
das gold in der staffel zuvor hatte
speerwerfer julian weber die zuschauer
mit seinem goldwurf von den sitzen
gerissen wer beflügelt hier wen das
publikum die sportler oder umgekehrt
wünscht es
war ein wahnsinns stimmung also ich habe
so etwas noch nicht erlebt an allen
wettkampfstätten euphorie über die
tollen leistungen über team bronze und
zweimal überraschungs gold der
turnerinnen der bahnradsport glänzt mit
achtmal gold ebenso die kanutinnen und
kanuten team deutschland wird
erfolgreichste nation mit insgesamt 60
medaillen 26 in gold eine zusätzliche
geht symbolisch an organisation und
publikum
diese elf tage sport waren fast schon
olympisch
fußball bundesliga gestern abend
abschluss des dritten spieltags mit
einem abschuss der bochumer mit 0 zu 7
gegen den vfl zu hause gegen die bayern
unter münchen mit drei siegen und 15 zu
1 toren tabellenführer ja im wahrsten
sinne des wortes spitze
selbst die so erfolgsverwöhnten bayern
feiern den besten saisonstart aller
bundesligisten in der geschichte in der
nach lewandowski zeit verteilen die
münchner ihre tore für den der vierten
minute das 1 0 von sany auch die
neuzugänge sind erfolgreich mattheis die
licht ist ebenso unter den schützen wie
der aus liverpool gekommene radio mann
der bereits dreimal getroffen hat den 7
0-endstand erzielt fabri bayern
überragend während die konkurrenz
schwächelt ja und alle tore alle partie
des dritten spieltages zusammengefasst
zu sehen bei uns auf heute die und in
der zdf mediathek dankeschön
sie ist blond
weltberühmt und lebensgefährlich
jedenfalls der sage nach die loreley
diese neue statue gibt es künftig an
mittelrhein in einer bürgerbefragung
setzte sich die blonde aus bronze gegen
52 andere entwürfe durch und lockt
künftig bei sankt goarshausen
rheinschiffer ins verderben sowie
weitere modelle dort wie gesagt eine
legende aber eine schaurig-schöne
hochwillkommen war ja der regen am
wochenende der aber nicht alle getroffen
hat wo und wann es in dieser woche bei
uns regnet das erfahren sie gleich von
katja vorne fahren marietta slomka
begrüßt sie um 21 45 zum heute journal
[Musik]
guten abend in den vergangenen tagen hat
es ja vor allen dingen in sachsen bayern
und baden württemberg richtig kräftig
geregnet und auch heute regnet es noch
weiter auch morgen wird diese steve
nicol wolken und regen von osten zu uns
rein schieben das hochbeet verabschiedet
sich richtung skandinavien und das -tief
melissa wird aus südwesteuropa noch mal
richtig heiße luft anzapfen denn morgen
liegen die temperaturen in frankreich
und in spanien schon wieder bei 30 35
grad unter den tiefen nicole bleibt es
dagegen kinder mit höchsttemperaturen
von 20 grad heute nacht sinken die
temperaturen in bayern auf kindle 12 bis
8 grad sonst hat die nacht bilder mit 17
bis 13 grad und auch in der nacht wird
es hier im osten noch einige regenwolken
geben im westen dagegen ist es zum teil
klar oder diesem wetter ändert sich über
tag nur wenig im westen gibt es einige
quellwolken aber zwischen der lübecker
bucht und dem bodensee scheint häufig
die sonne und hier im osten sind die
wolken dichter und bringen regen mit
deswegen liegen dort auch die
temperaturen nur so zwischen 19 und 24
grad im westen geht es dagegen zum teil
bis 32 grad rauf der mittwoch wird
trocken aber ab donnerstag ziehen dann
von osten einige gewitter auf schönen
abend noch